[Music]
[Applause]
luna the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to another
episode of the lehigh plan show powered
by the vc firm icon plus capital as
sponsored by blockfi so actually some
amazing news blockfy have now increased
their interest rates so i think you can
get up to nine and a half percent on
your stable coins um of course per adam
so that is really cool so i've left a
link for you in the description in the
comments section so check that out i
think you want to get some money when
you sign up so that's cool um and also
guys do not forget if you are watching
on youtube please hit the subscribe
button and hit the like button so you
never miss a video so joining me today
um it's gonna be pretty exciting
actually because i often find that this
space is very american-centric
but today it is all about the brits so
joining me is the british cryptocurrency
mainly bitcoin exchange coin corner guys
welcome to the show how you doing
thanks for having us
it's good to have you all here so i
think the best thing to do is to go
around and understand who everyone is
who do we have here so danny we'll start
with you
hey i'm danny um co-founder and ceo
uh hi guys molly head of marketing at
coin corner
i'm zach um tech lead here at clunk
corner and i'm david the accountant
[Laughter]
head office i love it
well it's good to meet you all because i
obviously i've met i've spoken with
danny and molly loads of times but i
haven't messed up met the rest of the
team so it's good to chat to you so
before we jump into everything for those
that don't know who coin corner um is
just give us the the basic understanding
of coin corner and what you guys do
yep so we are a um
bitcoin exchange um at the core of i
guess um focus around
uk focus and so we've been around since
2014 uh founded back in 2014 and um
operating in 45 sort of countries around
the world now um and continuing to look
to expand and based here in the alaman
um still all
here in the office i know the rest of
the world is still quite remote um but
as you can see we are all back in the
office and having some time
fortunate
yeah i've been seeing um molly your your
tick tock videos um saying good morning
to everyone i love it
it's so good
yeah well i basically
i don't know i just wanted to show
people who we were um because i think
sometimes encrypted can be a bit of a
faceless space and i think i don't know
whether i'm just a bit biased but i
think we've got quite a good team here
who are actually quite funny even even
you do yeah um so yes i just wanted to
create little videos to show people who
we are hopefully that helps like build
some trust as well with you know
everything in the space but uh yeah good
i'm glad you're enjoying them
yeah no i think it's great because a lot
of the time you know twitter is so
anonymous um it's where we all live and
putting a face to um companies and names
and things like that adds so much
credibility um but danny you mentioned
that you're expanding and you absolutely
are because you had the coin floor
acquisition so can you tell us about
this
yeah sure um so yeah we've
um
three weeks ago i kind of made the
announcement that we've um acquired coin
floor uh coin floor the
longest running uk bitcoin exchange
um we've known the guys for quite some
time they launched a little bit before
us um back in the day and
obviously met them at conferences and
always kept communication open with the
guys um i guess our visions between the
two companies have always been very
similar very bitcoin centric and bitcoin
focus
um
hopefully same sort of morals and same
sort of direction of where we wanted to
take um coin corner is effectively where
they wanted to take coin flow so and i
think the acquisition has come nicely in
terms of um allowing
uh coin corner to continue coin floors
vision um of where they wanted to take
on floor and bitcoin uh as a whole so
um we're very um proud happy to
have
uh bring the customers coin floor
customers on board now as well um and
welcome them into coin corner and
hopefully help carry on i guess the
legacy point flawless left behind um
being the longest uk exchange and um one
first i think it's an incredible uh
journey they went on and obviously we've
been through similar journey and know
the pains and pressures that you go
through
you mentioned having this similar vision
what is that vision
depends on
how long you got yeah
we got time and tell us what's the
vision what's the whole you know what's
the
the mission and the the idea
i think for us at the minute um
we are focused as mentioned there um
around bitcoin and trying to drive
bitcoin products and
having that as the the forefront
we are i know the coin floor crowd and
coin themselves uh they are very bitcoin
only um yeah they are in that direction
um we've even had we do have um ethereum
and like or an on-coin corner
which we've had for a few years and we
kind of added them years ago but we've
uh since
the
demand for them wasn't really there in
comparison to bitcoin it was always
the altcoins made up of about 10 of our
volume whereas 90 percent has always
been bitcoin uh so we've always focused
on bitcoin um regardless of that but
that in addition has meant they've just
kind of sat there in the background and
we've kind of um
turned our focus or kept our focus on
bitcoin we have had a lot of slack from
some of the coin floor customers coming
over that we're not bitcoin only
obviously really apologize for that um
for that crowd
without a doubt um but
you know that's just the way our system
uh our way our business has been uh
built initially um whether that was a
mistake to add altcoins back in the days
anyone's anyone's um opinion i guess at
that point
no
i think each to their own if they want
to buy bitcoin they can buy bitcoin you
know
but yeah i think obviously bitcoin has a
real world use case has the um
has a purpose i guess um
touch on something that's i guess live
today and active today in terms of the
shiba inu
oh my gosh you know that that's really
bad
this is just kind of helping a short
answer to your question uh you know
bitcoin has a real world use case and
purpose
and
it has the the foundations and the the
true technology and everything
and makes it what it is today whereas
you have the likes of the sheba e news
and the dogecoins and things like you
know they pop up and exactly you
obviously
[Laughter]
asking everybody what she being actually
does
and if you just read through the answers
you know goes up
clearly at least it goes up though
because like i saw i saw a funny tweet
um i'm not gonna name any particular
coins but i saw a funny tweet of
somebody saying you know hear a list of
all the meme coins and they had some
like reputable coins in them right and
then somebody just said well no that
that one doesn't go up um at least like
doge and she would eat it go up so i was
like fair enough
um but let's let's talk let's just say
let's talk about the market so because
it's been a really crazy week um yeah
shiba inu was up over 150
um in the last week of course bitcoin
hit new highs so um
dave or danny whoever wants to jump in
on this um what do you think really just
sparked this ball run because
some people were saying you know
that's it mark yasuko for example i
spoke with him and he wasn't that
convinced that we were going to see new
highs and yet we did
i think
the etf's played a big part in it i
would say
in terms of that was last week we saw a
bullish one from from that announcement
that they were all coming live
and then we saw that the new high and a
bit of a bounce off that i think that
that did play a part in my eyes
yeah
yeah i think so because the etf you know
broke records was it the
second largest
first day etf and
broke a 18 year old gold record
and the whole uh allowing an etf gives
huge access to people that couldn't buy
bitcoin before or restricted markets
that were restricted have now been
opened through it so of course i was
going to pump them on price
i think the anticipation to it as well
uh drove the price um i think generally
though
so
i'm surprised at mark ciusco's
comments to be fair on that in terms of
yeah i'll reach a high and
i do quite like a lot of marks uh no
he's great
yeah he's he's good he's i think he's
probably our biggest mount socks fan
that's amazing
tweets pretty much every friday with our
socks on um
which is always
nice to see um but he's always very
bullish so i'm quite surprised that his
his comments are
um but i think for me the way
again playing off history and everyone
looks at history uh to see
where we expect this ball runs to move
towards and
you know 2013 and 2017 they lasted a
year in real in terms of like the
bullish periods and during that year you
have your ups and downs and you have the
early spikes and the other movements and
it kind of gets things prepped and ready
and then you have a little bit of a lull
and a down period
and we've for us coming from corners
perspective in terms of um volumes and
new customer signups and things like we
can see the trends of what i'm moving
and
we've seen since
we had a bit of a crazy period from
january to april should we call it april
may then you know it dies off during
june july august
september started to come back again and
now october's starting to pick up a
little bit more again um so this is it's
pretty much the exact same um
time scales as what we saw in 2017 and
then we saw obviously what we saw in
2017 was october picked up november when
started to move and then december went
crazy um so
i know you can't always predict
something going forwards based off
history and but i think with
that in mind the harvard impacts the
uh the way the the sentiment of the
industry as a whole in terms of
you know companies coming on board
you've just seen mastercard jump on and
yeah announcements we're seeing paypal
and not people sorry um
obviously i've gotten gone live as well
but um
tesla looking like they're gonna start
accepting bitcoin again um you know
these
the etfs kicking off as they've touched
on their the sentiment again has
shifted towards a much more positive and
bullish sentiment uh in general as a
whole um
how accurate plan b is model
because he's like
well now he's 63 by the end of the month
throughout
what does plan b say doesn't he say
bye like he doesn't like 200k by q1 or
q2 or something next year is that what
he said he's he put the yeah so it's a
hundred and
it's quite range so there's no real
figures
yeah in all fairness we did one uh back
in june which stated the
um end-of-month figures of what he
expected bitcoin to be equal to or
greater than um and he's hit the mail on
the head to the thousand
every month since then um so this month
for october was 63k
so and we're at 61 at the minute we've
got three days together
but he says that i think he says that he
expects this bull market to continue for
the next six months which takes us to
around april so what do you think do you
think this is the last leg now
um
very different i i
i'll let somebody else talk
you
um
i would um
again looking at history i would have
always had in my head you know that the
ballroom might have another three months
to four months maybe in it in terms of
price movement and back to a new
all-time high
however
knowing the way the industry's moved and
the strength and the foundations it's
built along the way now and especially
this last year and there's no reason
that the ballroom cut or the bullish
period i guess rather than a ballroom
bullish period can continue on for yeah
six months nine months
right yeah if etfs are only just kicking
in will would be
the change of the four-year cycles for
bitcoin uh i don't know it's worth
remembering we're still pretty low in
google trends terms
we hit an all-time high i think google
trends was still about 30 weren't they
yeah it was whereas the huge ball in
december 17 wasn't it the google
translate would go up to 90 when it was
hitting 20. so you've got to think
it still looks like
attention's not been fully grabbed even
though we're at a new all-time high and
that they could go a lot further yeah
even from mainstream media you've had
much from them you just see more food
really like putting out more
energy foot the other day
why do you think they do that though
it's so funny because i i think i did
see something which said what does it
cost like a hundred dollars of
electricity to buy a cup of coffee with
bitcoin i think that was the headline i
can't remember
i saw the 5 000
pound crash headline which was
ridiculous
um why do you think it's so um
it's it's hostile and also they just
missed the point is it just pure
ignorance and um
yeah just ignorance and terrible
journalism or do you think there's like
an ulterior motive here they just don't
like it and they want to squash it
yeah how they report
it's a headline rather isn't it
anytime you would do it like crash or
anything it's just like all right what's
happened there it's just that
animalistic instinct to see what's going
on yeah but that's how i think like the
times does it really badly yeah it's
like every bitcoin article the times
right it's exactly the same follows the
same format they always mentioned you
know satoshi and all that it's just it's
lazy
journalism yeah a lot of that as well as
like from an seo perspective benefit
yeah it's like they're just yeah
if you focus too much on seo then that's
why every
uh is
which is what you are seeing i think
yeah the mainstream media is
lazy in that respect i think in terms of
what they're reporting what you just
touched on there the
um hundred dollar 100 pounds whatever it
was i think 100
yeah everything's dollars
yeah um
what was it for every drink i think
every cup of coffee i
think coffee um yeah in that respect but
again this comes back to education a
little bit but you know they are
blindly or
choosing almost i think or i feel to
ignore the education that's around it
but why facts because it makes for a
better headline i guess is the way that
it is
um which is difficult we i know we've
had this conversation before though in
terms of education
um
it makes our lives hard because we're
constantly having to work on satan fight
against them sort of uh
journalistic um clickbait headlines and
the content that they're putting out
there and we've we've did our own
research in terms of that um with the
lightning network on top of bitcoin and
how many
transactions you can make um per
um
kilowatt hour but in terms of
carbon output that you would put from
bitcoin in comparison to real-world
products and real-world things like
orange juice glass of orange juice is
equal to
z11 lightning transactions and that's
including the whole of the bitcoin
network in there as well so when you
actually take things properly into
consideration and weigh things up in
terms of compare that to real world
things that people used to like a glass
of glass of orange juice and you can
start to understand that you know this
is a non-issue um but it doesn't matter
calling it a non-issue and telling
everybody the real facts doesn't create
good headlines it's also much easier to
publish if an article
has been publishing before so like no
one does their own research in terms of
transactional stuff they literally just
copy it down so like for like five years
everyone was using that same item called
the same article it was the same book
yeah
yeah and even though it's proven like
it's just easy because they've got
multiple sources to validate and that's
how they validate what was the book
called of bananas the
uh
that was about how much electricity
emails used was yeah um so
for the last five to ten years all
journalists have been referencing this
one book for the amount of energy that
emails take up well that was
brought it was released in 2011 but
there was a new book released in 2020
but even since the new book was released
with new updated numbers
journalists and everyone are still using
the old numbers and still putting out
that content so we did our um sort of
research project we did was using the
new numbers and the new content from the
book and to update everything which was
in favor more so than for emails and
things like that which is better as we
expect as time goes on as technology
improves uh the electricity usage
becomes less and less for these these
products
um but yeah the media are not still
using that
and choosing to ignore it i guess no one
sat there all day sending emails worried
about all the electricity
or even just you know when you go on
holiday and you leave the fridge on you
know the fridge is on all day
even when you go out leave the lights on
and things like that nobody talks about
it christmas lights but we won't go into
that but what i do think would be a
great headline which would be very pro
bitcoin would be something like um
bitcoin could be the end of banks you
know like what is pro bitcoin why can we
have a headline like that anyway so i
often think there's something kind of i
don't know
an ulterior motive in my personal
opinion but um you know you're always
having to come up against something and
obviously in the us they had the whole
infrastructure bill which um obviously
wasn't very cryptocurrency friendly at
all um so what's the situation like in
the uk i do remember that the fca a few
months ago um put 11 000 pounds into
educating people about the dangers of
cryptocurrency so have you had any
issues with the fca
um that was the 11 million wasn't it
that um yeah educating on
warning people i guess in terms of uh
the risk of cryptocurrency investments
and purchases um
we've got nothing but to say about this
we haven't loved them
and no we i think regulation everywhere
around the world it's coming
the industry and people will um
for the most part you know you kind of
have to accept that and that's the way
the world works and the laws i know you
can try and
not rebel but you can try and fight
against that such um and we do our our
part with the regulators with the the
aleman fsa with the uk fca we try and
even further afield and when we're
communicating with them and trying to
work with them it's about what can
make them comfortable in terms of how
they protect
um
some of it for me the protecting
consumer is a different question to like
the anti-money laundering side of things
um but the from the anti-money
laundering perspective from the fca fsa
and so on um it's what makes them
comfortable and is still able to create
um a realistic business i guess a
business model and an industry uh for
the bitcoin industry in the crypto
industry um
you always have to kind of meet in the
middle somewhere with them and that's i
guess what we've done over the years and
we've tried to
push back where he's needed and
you know the regulator's the other day
are not
that educated on these industries that
they go into to
to regulate um so they have to and they
we appreciate that they appreciate that
they have to take guidance from um the
industry as a whole and that's what they
they often do and it's just a case of
communication and making sure we can um
meet in the middle somewhere of course
obviously things always can go too far
the bit license was probably a prime
example of that in new york um and still
is that they still don't seem to be
budging and seems to be getting worse
recently um
but that's i guess uh them
overreaching um um whether that's a a
wall street um big bank uh kind of
poking the regulator there to say look
clamp down on this industry or not
i don't know you've got to remember the
banks are highly regulated themselves so
yeah it's it's almost like a lever it
has to be 11 playing field as we we're
talking about that's competition with
them because you can't expect the fta to
regulate them so highly and then ignore
this growing business that's the bank's
argument effectively and that's where
they're poking the regulators they go
and look at these guys and then you know
the the bit license in new york is
probably the one the only one that's
gone over the top uh an
overreach um
they've been overreaching in terms of
what they've been doing and there has
been cases where they're trying to like
people like
like by using nuts there's this square
taking a roundhold like using
traditional existing frames existing
frameworks
yeah existing frameworks for the new
industry like to say because they're not
they don't
understand the full ins and outs of this
industry of how bitcoin works
essentially and we have had cases where
we've had some government organizations
and he come in here to actually educate
them so we are actually responsible for
spreading that message and it's probably
part of what coin corner tries to do is
put education at the front of what we do
in terms of trying to get the message
across and this isn't a scary industry
this is actually some a product that can
help a lot of people
i think what always just blows my mind
is that you have people who have never
even um touched a cryptocurrency in
their life not that you can physically
touch it but you know people who have
never
even held a cryptocurrency um making
rules and regulations um about it and
particularly in america um you know
talking about taxing um unrealized um
unrealized gains which
which just really blew my mind um
do do you have any thoughts on on that
guy's taxi unrealized games
it's crazy that's one it's just crazy
you can't really yeah i think it got
thrown out yesterday right did it
it's a target there's you know more
wealthy people with a lot of property
that you know going up in value and that
they aren't getting taxed on in any way
shape or form but
um it's crazy to think you could
actually levy a tax on someone would
they haven't got
they haven't realized that the capital
wasn't released
to then pay the tax bill it's crazy so
it did get thrown out quite quickly um
the the worry that people have in the uk
is then bitcoin's obviously subject to
capital gains tax and
the budget announcement yesterday the
capital gains as
people were expecting a movement in it
in terms of
the allow the allowable you basically
got an allowance in the uk about 12k
that says you you earn up to this
in a game and after that you pay taxes
on it but um people are expecting that
to be sharply reduced in terms of we
know that uk government have to pay back
an awful lot of
code good measures and
but it looks like they're actually
freely spending and capital gains wasn't
touched yesterday in terms of in terms
of the allowances
so there's the thresholds on maybe the
threshold
so what is it you get 12 um i don't know
because i don't sell so
what you'll get
yeah it's an option for people just
so what is it
you get 12 you get 12 000 pounds um free
not taxed and then what is it isn't it
like 20 or something after that
yeah there's a higher and lower rates
the higher rates 20 and it's different
for houses and secondary properties and
bits and pieces but it is something that
you have to be aware of if you are
trading
bitcoin you do have to keep a record of
your pool so it's a something that you
just if you keep good records most
people probably well actually nowadays
with a bullish one people probably do
have to think about that threshold but
historically they haven't had to
yeah or you just don't sell you know you
take a loan out against your bitcoin
um
and then you build generational wealth
so you guys are offering loans soon is
that right
soon yes yeah yeah we um
got approved in the element for um the
loan license
so we've got that
um we will be launching hopefully before
the end of the year um with the bitcoin
back loans uh which will
have more detail on that i guess as um
nearer the time um but yeah approved and
ready to go just um coin floor
acquisitions kind of took priority and
the other products will be coming soon
i have to do it like i've never i
haven't actually taken a loan out yet
against my bitcoin but i will have to do
it um every i like all the cool kids are
doing it now i'm joking yeah it's like
one of those things you have like
unchained capital and all these all
these different companies um offering
that service which is really cool um but
yeah you you also have the um you've
also integrated the lightning network so
uh more and more people are are doing
transactions um on the lightning network
which is really really interesting i
think it's actually
allowed the the transaction fees to drop
on the base layer so talk to me about
this um how can people use the lightning
network with you
you're all the lightning people
i suppose it helps back to what we're
talking about the starting times of our
vision so i know danny and me
specifically
always tried to keep up with the
technical side of bitcoin we were right
we were early ourselves personally in
the lightning network and we always plan
to integrate just have to wait for the
network itself to mature and then when
we thought it was a good time we um we
integrated into the exchange
so it just allows um customers to make
use of basically we offer free
deposits and withdrawals online network
and just allows users to come on
use either on chain or lightning in one
wallet system so it's very very simple
to users they can send out over the line
network or send in over the lightning
network
micro transactions all that jazz
yeah i think part of this as well is
that we introduced lightning in the
january this year wasn't it yeah january
this year um
and
that was our first stepping stone you
know that's not the final form and
there's still lots of development and
lots of products to come on the back of
this uh we have something that will be
coming in the next uh for end of
november um which
um we
are you guys are you going to be at uh
coinfest like are you
i have no idea what what's the date for
is the end of november or beginning of
november end of november
unsure
i'm sure
25th 26th 27th down about that time
i'm not sure i haven't decided
um so we'll hopefully be there and we're
hoping to announce uh something there at
that point which is all related to the
lightning side of things and
developments we're doing um so that'll
hopefully be very exciting uh something
that looking forward to
the and that's one of the little
projects around lighting so now we have
lightning capabilities within the system
we're able to build various things on
top of that and zach um more so than
myself these days at the minute uh has
been working around all sorts of um
the
even the going forwards to the layer
threes and doing um
forgot the name uh that was working on
the other week what are the layer threes
hang on
layer three what
impervious which was um
did you potentially get the webpage live
uh no no not quite uh
impervious is basically a
layer three on top of lightning which is
essentially like a decentralized
internet so it allows
uncensored communication between several
nodes
so that's still very early just like the
lightning's very early but we've been
playing around with that as well and i
suppose just going back to the lightning
network i think el salvador has been a
big eye-opener to a lot of people
obviously historically i think
me and danny have obviously been
into the lighting network from pretty
much the beginning
we had several people tell us it's you
know fake tech and that kind of thing
and then to see
what's happening in el salvador which
wouldn't be possible without the lining
network it's kind of proven all those
they say is wrong and just giving
everyone more conviction in terms of you
know this is the future of payments on
top of bitcoin
um it works
yes there's issues but
you know
we're still alien bitcoin we're still
early in line
so wait i want to i still want to go
back to the layer three
so
what's it called again
impervious hang on i'm still here let me
just hit my camera
my camera goes off every 30 minutes it's
really annoying unless i hit it um okay
so layer three um
so so that's like the internet what does
that mean
so
let's so you've got we've got bitcoin
obviously layer one um
obviously these things have been built
on top and you've got lightning on top
of that um and then now somebody's doing
something called impervious which is now
being built on top of lightning and
using the lightning network and
lightning layer to um communicate
via their own protocol that they've
created now um and
that is allowing i think was it just
this week was it last week they
announced the browser that they're doing
yeah they're answering they're building
a browser which will you know sit on top
of this so like just your normal
internet browser but instead of visiting
websites
um you'll be visiting impervious nodes
which is using the lightning as the
rails underneath
so you can you can basically host
websites on that and it's kind of like
uncensorable
you know you've got issues like in china
at the moment they restrict the internet
and north korea and all that kind of
thing
it's kind of like decentralizing the
internet as we know it
so how do you access it this browser
that they're building
it just like i guess
the minute you say like you download
chrome for example you would just
download um the impervious browser for
example and you would then what the
extension
or no it's a new browser it's a brand
new action
and then you would enter any url in
there that's on the impervious network
on the line network and it would allow
you to
effectively load that website based off
other people around the world serving it
to you via the lightning network
interesting concepts and
yeah it's very it's very much proof of
concept at the moment not not in full
production
for people to use but um it's exciting
yeah it's just another one of the things
you have to keep
you know we have you've got your bitcoin
and bitcoin has its value layer the
investment angle and the product in
itself the store of value store wealth
we're going to call it and then we've
then got the lighting network now which
is becoming more of the actual payments
side of things and the money movement
and moving money around the world
um
obviously we're now having quite a focus
on the moving the money around the world
peace and enlightening side and working
on lots of things around that but then
of course as that matures and that
moves on in the industry and more things
happen um moore's develops and then we
will see these these layer threes and
even layer twos i'll interact um and you
know it's this talk of
thinking further further down the line
you talk of the cbd season that the um
so all these central bank digital
currencies that are potentially coming
out and as long as they all stick to
some form of
um
same real sense same protocol in some
respects and make them all interoperable
with each other um eventually maybe
you'll be able to interact with
bitcoin's lightning network with the
bank of england's
gbp stablecoin that they create um in a
decentralized interoperable model
yeah i was going to say
you've got to hope that they look at
something like that eventually because
although if they don't
they are just creating they're
recreating
you know you're reinventing the wheel if
they don't look to that um the advantage
over
making that interoperability and with
the rest of the currencies around the
world whether they be decentralized
bitcoin cryptocurrencies or whether they
be other central banks currencies um
then you know you want them
interoperable with each other so they
can interact and move things around
of course they might feel like loses
control and that's a decision they're
gonna have to make and see how that
plays out but if they don't do that are
they just reinventing the wheel of what
we already have in the system now so yes
yeah is yeah so that's your answer you
need to make it an open network that
everyone can communicate with the way
bitcoin is moving things
yeah i mean reinventing the wheel plus
diminished privacy and more control
um but yeah i mean it's going to be
interesting to see how to see how it
plays out like cbdc's are coming i think
what was really funny actually was um so
um this cbn central bank of nigeria just
launched the e naira this week and then
the app just crashed so
i i don't really like i don't like um
cbdc's at all and so when the app
crashed i was like that's good um
but
but i mean it's interesting all this um
development that's happening on bitcoin
because often a lot of the development
that we see in this space is happening
on ethereum so
do you think that eventually we will get
to a place where bitcoin is doing what
ethereum is doing um you know i know
i've seen conversations about um nfts on
bitcoin and things like that
yep yeah i think so um nfts on bitcoin
is possible
it's been done several years ago it's
just
i feel like most of the developers on
bitcoin are focused on developing rather
than marketing
um so it often goes unheard i think
yeah i think it's real world products i
think over um current hype without
wanting to insult anyone um i think
current hype around nfc's and you know
we've seen it
all through the different cycles and
altcoins we've had um
blockchain this blockchain that we've
had um icos we've had d5 we've now kind
of been nft territory um and these these
height periods come with the next new
fad um that people jump onto and um
don't get me wrong in some respects
sometimes it brings and attracts people
to the industry as a whole
and that can work in a positive manner
um
sometimes we say
but obviously they're not
solving real world problems you know
some of them may eventually find a use
case where they can solve a real world
problem which would be amazing and great
and i look forward to seeing them once
um but
again with the noise and that's what
we've done at coin corner is trying to
not let that noise distract us and try
and focus on what we believe has that
long-term uh sustainable
um lifespan of a product and a service
um which is bitcoin and the things being
developed around that
um in terms of the uh a good way maybe
to explain or to put this um
on bitcoin with the smart contract side
so we've got um simplicity is one of the
things that's been worked on um by quite
a few of the core devs uh which allow
for uh easier smart contract platform
basically on top of bitcoin um so that
is moving and coming and okay that's
still very least well not very early
stages we're kind of moving with that a
little bit now
um
so
short answer is yes there's smart
contracts pieces coming into bitcoin
already you know lightning in this in
itself is the smart contracts on bitcoin
um so they are there and they've been
used but they're being used in real
world use cases rather than creating
jpegs
sold for millions of dollars um
eventually though the way out the best
way for me to describe this eventually
you know five years ten years down the
line once bitcoin um bitcoin has that
strong foundation and that these truly
decentralized strong foundation um
that is the key thing for me and that's
one of the things that is um very very
beneficial from a bitcoin perspective
and if we look at the likes of even
ethereum
um the
cardanos the dots whatever or the ones
they've got around these days uh lose
track of how many there is and what
they're doing but they
are built with very much um some form of
centralization for a lot of the time and
um
often the the tech you know we saw just
last night was it the
financial something or other that flash
loan that got robbed for a couple of
hundred million dollars or whatever it
was um and nothing but that usually uh
books in the smart contract piece and so
on but you know there's they're moving
quickly and breaking things and losing
money whereas bitcoins move slowly and
build an incredible foundation to build
on five to ten years time you're a new
company wanting to build some form of
smart contracts basis on a decentralized
platform
who do you pick the one with the strong
foundations or the ones that keep moving
quickly and breaking things
and eventually you know everybody will
come back to or come to the um strong
foundation that you want to build a
long-term business on not something
that's going to be building quickly
breaking and killing your business um so
i think long term
that's kind of the way i would envision
it going and i think bitcoin will slowly
um remove a lot of the
altcoins use cases it already has you
know most all coins don't really have a
use case like this sorry i've gone
heavier to help them no it's okay i
think i think it's going to be um really
interesting to see what happens hang on
just bear with me bear with me one
second somebody has just entered my
apartment but everyone
[Laughter]
bear with me one sec somebody has just
entered my apartment hang on this is
very interesting because it's live and
there's nothing i can do so just give me
one sec
yeah sorry i've got heavy on that with
any more to add to the um
how much you hate old coins yeah
[Music]
spoke on behalf um it gosh that was
crazy do you know what i heard them
knocking when you were on there and i
thought they'd leave it was housekeeping
i'll tell you i'll just act to be honest
and tell you what happened i actually
burnt something in the oven yesterday um
and so
i burnt something in the oven and so i i
told the airbnb i needed them to come
clean it so now they're just banging on
the door to clean it but
10 minutes okay um anyway yeah i think i
think it's really interesting um i think
that um
right now there are a lot of altcoins um
slowly losing value and i definitely
agree with you in that sense um
and i think that one of the things which
really annoys me about
that kind of part of this industry is
that a lot of companies just create
these coins for no reason just for the
sake of keeping you within the ecosystem
um you know whether it's like
cash back or
governance tokens or things like that
i'm often just like you don't really
need it you know what i mean um so i i
do get frustrated um but you have a card
coming as well isn't is that correct
yes yeah so can you tell me about the
card
uh
yeah well
as much as we can uh yeah there's always
like it's always like you can and you
can't really save it
uh yes we've got the card um coming soon
which will effect would be like a debit
card back to your coin corner account um
so that'd be like instantly spendable
from your bitcoin balance
um we're hoping that comes um before the
end of the year but um still some
regulatory pieces that we're just
getting in place at the minute um so
once they're done um we'll have a bit
more information and announcements for
that um but yeah it's uh
effective bitcoin back to gbp
we'll also have a euro one as well
coming with a euro one might come into
the uh new year more than maybe q2 next
year
um so yeah looking forward to that
and are there any more updates that you
can tell us we know we've got the loans
coming we've got the cards coming you've
currently got the cash back which is
very very cool i've been using that and
enjoying that
good that's good here
um
we have
the kids accountable
oh yes this is what i wanted to ask you
actually so tell us you have you have
like this kids savings account coming
explain
yeah i don't know like
well me and dave are both parents dave's
got three kids i don't even know i've
got three kids yeah everybody really
likes it
i might not mention it tells us that
he has three kids people don't
understand
three i've got one yeah exactly
um
yeah i don't know i guess like i think
i've asked for it
previously i think it's i think it's a
great idea
um because when my son was born i
bitcoin was something i wanted to buy
for him but then it's like at the moment
i just buy bitcoin and keep it my own
account there's no differentiating
between the account so he just it's just
all mashed into one um and i know i have
a bank account with a savings account
for him which is like under his name and
separate and
that's kind of what i wanted
for us guys as well
i know a lot of other parents i've
spoken to
yeah no i don't like them but i i got my
kids on paper wallets those are very
insecure they're in the baby that's
amazing
but it's just like anyone could just
clean them out i've not emptied them it
was i pretty
so i've been after it for a while there
somewhere like molly says somewhere to
keep it organized and separate so you
know how much bitcoin each one of your
kids has got and maybe not giving well
definitely not given access to for a
while but just just
to get them on the first rung if you
will
yeah of course yeah
so yeah i'm super excited about that um
you guys are working on at the moment
yeah we hope that again that'll be
another one before the end of the year
it's a lot before the end of this year
yeah i think it's kind of important
though because everybody talks about
bitcoin for the next generation and
generational wealth
um
so i think i think it's going to be
something that people
will like yeah yeah it's definitely
something that's underserved in in the
industry the minute i don't think
there's i've never actually seen one
i haven't i haven't that's like a that's
like a physical one yeah yeah that means
kids but yeah
confusing so yeah definitely something
that's underserved and like zach says
that you know you talk about um a
generational wealth of bitcoin savings
and that's what people's mentality is
and to pass it on to people so you know
that it makes perfect sense and so
certainly underserved and hopefully we
can
come and help serve that area
sector industry that that or public that
want that product um soon uh other than
that we have
the lightning stuff which we will
announce at coinfest um
it's not that far away but we will be
announcing it out by the first day don't
worry um so that'd be quite cool it'll
be an exciting product um hopefully a
world first one as well i think right
i'm excited i'm excited to hear how it
all goes but no i think you know molly
you're right when you say that we always
talk about getting the next generation
um into bitcoin um but nobody's really
building anything to really allow that
to happen um so yeah i think i think
that's going to be great um so guys do
you have any last final um things to
announce um before we we say goodbye how
can people um join coincorner and follow
everyone
where can they find us um
all on twitter mostly yeah socials yeah
twitter mainly we're very active on
twitter we're very accessible yeah we
ever have any issues with our platform
you can dm that's true
or me or dave or nothing yeah i do try
not to
help you
don't bother
unless you are
um yeah that's one of the things i we
it's frustrating again in the industry
as a whole and it feels like the world
these days not even just our industry
like customer service side of things has
been terrible um over the years yeah
from a lot of companies and you know i'm
not saying coincorn is amazing and we're
immune to that in any way whatsoever and
what i am saying though is something
that we want to focus on going forwards
and particularly is
customer experience and customer service
going through and that's part of the
team being public on socials on twitter
and easy access to anybody at the
company that you need to talk to you
know you don't see that from
you know think of any other companies
out there in the world there's very few
like you know take google take microsoft
take whoever you know you can't just
jump onto
a social media platform like twitter and
dm the team there and have the
communication that you need
and obviously as you know if we get to
the google microsoft size of the company
of course it gets more difficult to be
able to do that don't get me wrong i'm
not naive
in that respect
um but you know it's customer service is
something that we want to excel at um
for the industry as a whole uh helping
the education side for um our customers
and all the customers uh all the um
bitcoins out there so
um so yeah that's where we are where we
hang out and easily accessible come and
dm me if we don't respond
instantly give it time awesome time uh
sometimes i think myself and molly get
uh overwhelmed with messages coming in
um so yeah we will reply he just
sometimes takes a little bit of time
yeah i think having that social media
presence is so important i'm always
talking about this and i think you know
like the way we started this
conversation off was talking about how
much credibility um it provides and
often
with the traditional financial system
it's hard to you know get in touch with
someone and that kind of relationship
just isn't there um so i think having
that kind of peer-to-peer touch um when
it comes to customer service in our
community is really important um so guys
i want to thank you so much for coming
on um everyone please follow coincorner
and also check out their cashback
service it is amazing um they i think on
jd sports i bought some shoes and i got
like four percent cash back or something
um in bitcoin so yeah check that out
it's really cool even boots as well
contact lenses um yeah i've just bought
it with it with a bunch of different
stuff so um check that out it's a
browser extension so yeah take a look
cool thank you
good to have you on and guys don't
forget to um tune in next week for
another conversation about bitcoin we'll
see you then
[Applause]
[Music]